welcome to camp et thank you we have
Adam I don't know if you like candied we
have candy we have juice boxes just so
you know what sugar ha l please guys dig
in with cheers haha what were you a
camper growing up um I was I'd like a
day camper cuz growing up I was a
competitive gymnast oh so one year I
went to like a sleepaway camp it was
gymnastics themed so that's like my only
camp experience was really intense
gymnastics so if you went to summer camp
today what other YouTube creator would
you want to be your bunk buddy oh that
is an excellent question other ones yeah
I think I would choose a youtuber that
doesn't live in Los Angeles so someone I
don't get to see very often i would go
with my friend call is cool that's her
youtube channel i think we'd have a lot
of fun at summer camp so fun how cool is
it that you have a platform like this to
like be yourself your authentic self but
also like interact with all these people
who like are looking for someone to
relate to it's really cool to like the
ability to have an influence on people's
lives is incredible and it's especially
validating when people are like oh this
video gave me a lot of confidence or you
being yourself on the internet and gave
me the confidence like go make a new
friend like that to me is incredible
what are you working on next like what's
coming up in 2016 for you ah the main
thing I've been kind of focusing on is I
have a talk show on the full screen app
called is all good with Alexis cheese
all you can full screen calm or the App
Store you can download it there and
basically it's the show is all about
talking to people that I find
interesting inspiring young people and
seeing them from a fresh perspective
that is all so that's what I've been
like mainly focus and that's why she's
so good at this damn like i feel like i
met your talk show this is great well
thanks for hanging out with us and so
come back next summer meet you will have
more like we'll have trees and stuff but
okay cheers to VidCon